she's beautiful funny oh you know we
really get along well and I really like
her okay except for one thing oh boy she
is a horrible kisser kissing is a really
important part of any relationship and
church I kind of take uh more
uh simple and surgical approach to
French kissing so Surgical
Patrick Bateman dude
Runk
hello hello hello
[Music]
hey hey
dude it's Lifeline it's Lifeline wow
the worst starting of anything
it's Lifeline why do people say they
hate Arrowhead water so much dude I
don't know they say it's trash water
people act like it's trash water like
it's like Aquafina or something Aquafina
is trash water you know how I know that
because I one time accidentally threw a
big piece in one of those big trash bins
a big piece of what just about yeah a
big furniture and I threw it and
I don't know if this is dumb that I
didn't think about this ahead of time or
whatever but I felt real dumb okay
I didn't like very quickly turn my head
you didn't very well or have a mask on
yeah so what happened is it went in yeah
and just all this detronous of like
years years worth of garbage however
well the Bin's been there for like
[__] years but and they're [__] all
over the bottom of it that God knows
when the last time it was like cleaned
and it just comes just and it went in my
face I almost threw
up for like three or four days
I was like the memory of it was like
this is disgusting anyway that's what
Aquafina tastes like
so because that's what Aquafina tastes
like well you know because I've tasted
butter oh yeah that's what it tastes
like yeah yeah trash water oh my God
that's so gross it's like a metallic
trash taste that I get when I drink
alcohol no no no no sorry Dasani does
the same okay well that explains it then
yeah now why is your
um
why did you not know to not move your
face
that's weird when you first asked me
about what I meant when I said that it
sounded like you were like confused as
to why I would have thought to do that
no no no no no that's why I asked you
because I'm like well surely this is not
what you mean because you would turn
your face I didn't though I didn't and I
paid the [__] price dude
photographing prices did you think you
were gonna die no no no no no no it did
go in my eyes and nose though it was
like in my body you know what I'm saying
it wasn't like a Wi-Fi caught it was
like it got in me you know what I mean
wow that's disgusting it was in fact
just thinking about it I'm like really
wow yeah yeah so wait so that take that
you feel like that's what a hint of
Dasani water tastes like yeah correct
yeah wow and have you had you had Dasani
before that
yes so when it hit you were you like
that's like the sounding water
understand dude a lawyer right now wow
wow uh when it hit me no no no no no no
no no not until the next time I had it
Dasani was I triggered yeah dude that's
hilarious yeah the Sony and Aquafina are
are they really the same thing well I
don't know if they're the same thing I
think one's by Coca-Cola okay maybe they
both are but everything's by Coca-Cola
Dasani is the worst one I would say Okay
Aquafina is bad anything other than
those two are fine
I don't have it like I know you know
what you know what dude and some people
are like dude yes and some people like I
have no idea if you drink a bottle of
Fiji Water
it it smells doesn't taste like but the
smell is that a very strong paint
it smells like a [__] paint store
when they're mixing paint right in front
of your schnauzeronski dude I'm telling
you okay it is so when you lift it up
you smell it that's what it smells like
but it doesn't taste like that take the
top off yeah yeah put the top down bring
the bottle with your arm and a hand to
bring them both close to your mouth as
it gets closer and closer you think oh
where are people painting things then
when you get it close to your mouth you
think oh this bottle was formerly used
as a paint can and then you drink it and
when you remove the bottle you realize
oh it's not the water at all it's the
thing I just put in my face which is
plastic which is a Fiji bottle of water
is this from sure you go is this water
from Sherwin William Sherman William
what is it sure sure
is this from Schwing Williams
look guys
this is lifeline and uh this one airs on
June 25th which means I will be in Las
Vegas coming up and I will be in
Knoxville and Charlotte and also
uh
butt head
butt heads gosh I keep saying the f word
yeah what's wrong with you man you know
what what is it I got a few things wrong
with me I don't know what they are but
I'm working on it and I'm aware of it so
don't come at me I will be in Las Vegas
I will be in Charlotte I will be in
Knoxville Little Rock Arkansas that's
the one uh Nashville can't wait Calgary
Edmonton Ottawa Montclair that's what we
say Montreal but Jamaican music
so go to chrisley.com to get those
tickets
um we have a patreon here at lifeline
and we've got some episodes out Lifeline
luxury patreon.com Lifeline luxury that
is no video submissions that's just me
and my brother uh and their fun shows uh
they're actually some of the funnest so
going over there and sign up uh it's uh
and you can also access the backlogged
episodes we already have a few of them
on there go to watch lifeline.com uh or
leave us a message at the number
and
um or click a link in the description
below hey you can do that too yeah yeah
true you could do that uh we've got the
hot merch the lifeline merch
lifelinemerch.com and if you really want
to get down and dirty into the weeds
into the serious neuroses of the
amygdala and such and such you can book
a one-on-one advice session with me yeah
boy pimpin pimpin bad about it so baby
baby
and Booyah the most boring guy
mattelier.com thank you very much uh
here's the deal also you know be great
leave a comment actually leave a comment
I want to know because I I do sometimes
look at the YouTube comments what I want
to know what uh
what turns you on no bad I want to know
what no wanna know no I want to know
what water give me like a dog getting
deeper and deeper I want to know what
Waters foreign
because I get it I don't understand I
genuinely don't I don't like no no I
like Arrowhead yeah
um
like I like it on the on the level that
I like Crystal Geyser and Evian like the
good ones you know Poland Spring is so
good that's like the arrowhead of the
East Coast Poland Spring regular one
spring in regular water no like I only
think of uh carbonated what I think oh
yeah regular water yeah it's uh uh Palm
Spring in New York was what I always
drank because it tasted the most like
Arrowhead because they don't have
Arrowhead there all right when I lived
back in New York when I lived on the
east side you know my mind my heart is
in New York but I believe New York and
um no but so wait there was something I
need New York dude and I said I believe
New York I knew someone who said I need
New York so that person is terrible I
agree they also went to locking out of
high school do you know what I mean oh
geez and then two years later they're
like oh I need New York oh that's
terrible and I was like uh I need to
slap you um you know what I mean yeah
that's violence yeah we don't condone
that but there is something I wanted to
say and now I don't remember and I'm
pissed so so what do we do about that so
I'm pissed I am it was interesting too
God damn it couldn't have been that
interesting no I hate when people say
that you know what I hate when they say
well if you can't remember it wasn't
important yeah no but what if you're so
wrong about how brains work when you say
that you like no the person's saying
okay so insecure I thought I was talking
about you
uh you might as well just say
because that is your level of
intelligence do you know what I mean
though yeah you're that dumb so it'd be
easier to just go bad
Michael Jackson
uh because that is your intelligence
level and we'll all understand that that
is your intelligence level quicker if
you just say yep
all right dude you know that's so
annoying but it's quicker you know I
like when people are up front Okay it's
like when people are like I'm not what
if someone people like I'm not funny
it's like better than someone who makes
a joke and expects your life and they're
not funny people that know themselves
are better well yeah of course so that's
why people who are dumb should do that
nobody really there are very few people
who think they're not funny which is
crazy I know right yeah
people think they know what's funny to
understand if I kill it I kill it well
that was too fast what you said I don't
know what it was I'd like to see him
trying to stand up I kill it I kill it
is what I said oh so remember uh should
we talk about it or a family member oh
how he's good at making bread no oh
don't I mean that's that would be so
boring like hey we have a cousin that's
amazing at making bread no well the
other cousin will that just our third
cousin I'm not gonna mention any names
don't mention the name of it yeah said
what you tell the story it happened to
you why do I I wasn't we were in a
basement we were in a basement were you
there yeah yeah we were celebrating
Grandma Daddy's
90th birthday oh and everybody went back
to where she's you know where she lives
and we threw this big birthday party the
whole extended family was there and one
of them cornered
Chris were you there I was standing
right there oh you are so I was there I
thought I you weren't there and I was I
was like I gotta get out of here oh wait
I thought I meant on a whole trip you
mean was that they're physically in the
space yes yes I was yes so then both is
yes so it doesn't matter to specify yeah
but I thought you were talking about a
different trip that I actually didn't go
on and I thought maybe you were like
were you there in total there's no
reason to be that mad at me I'm [__]
pissed because it was obvious so
um
so okay
so loud
it won't be on the microphone so no one
will know you know
insecure so they'll see your reaction
yeah it was good well then unless
they're just listening to it which would
be the worst then it's no see your
reaction of two guys little guys and it
was good
small people so um
anyway a third base coach
so
go ahead back and forth I'm giving the
sign to the audience so um
they were in a basement there was like
an I don't even want to say what family
member was but it was an older person
because I don't want to you know yeah
because they listen yeah and she was
smoking I guess we were there for a
break I was down there I was smoking you
were smoking with me she was smoking too
that's why we were down there though I
wasn't smoking I don't smoke you came
with me man but you said you were
smoking with me I said you were I was
smoking you were with me is what I said
now stop yourself you can tell the story
not yelling but so
um she was there and she was smoking and
she was like oh yeah you were there now
I remember it she was like um
you know everyone always told me and one
of my dream jobs and what I think I
could always do but it's just like you
know I would always be really good at it
you know what it is
and I was like Wow here it comes because
I knew I said what she goes like this
stand up
actually what she said was the smoking
happened but she said stand up comedy
standing in her thick in her thick East
Coast accent yeah
I'll never forget it dude it was really
wild like it's so weird to say I could
have done stand-up comedy because
it's insulting too well it's like if I
went up to Randy Johnson and I was like
you know what I could do pitch yeah it
is insulting but
um or you go up to David tell me you
know what I can do eat a lot and get fat
you know what I can do have the most
massive head in the entire unit it is
insulting but I don't get insulted by it
because I don't really I know but
recognizing it's insulting doesn't mean
you have to get it yes I know but it is
it's the opposite it is insulting so so
but
it it's so weird because
you
it's it's one of those things that
you just you have to it has to be your
whole life
so it's not even like do you have the
talent
you you just the reason why you're not a
stand-up comic is because you're not a
stand-up comic you don't have the drive
to do this also didn't do it I I know
it's weird it's a real reason you're not
the biggest reason you're not is because
you never did it it's the weirdest thing
because nobody says like you know I
could have been a surgeon
like it's just it's stand-up comedy
that's like I always thought I think
they do that with entertainment
positions as well acting they think that
they do but yeah but yeah I guess they
do yeah they do yeah singer yeah singer
for sure yeah to be loved Oh What a
Feeling to be loved
it
uh all right should we go should we do
yeah I forget what I was gonna say about
the thing something about Waters and
then something else happened and I'm
pissed off doesn't matter uh all right
all right let's get into it here we go
what's up you guys I have a simple but
important question for you
yes take that out of your nose no okay
sorry
now we're racist all right [__] I was
racist [__] it's okay
what's up you guys I have a simple but
important question for you
I've been tanning recently at the pool
okay at my apartment complex now you can
imagine
the uh the commoners that come on a
daily basis and I'm trying to get my tan
on right now it's come to the point
where I have a
huge timeline over down where my package
resides
okay and um I've been pondering getting
a speedo to minimize the amount of uh
blank canvas if you will we get it I
mean the terminology and I'm trying to
optimize my tanning gains so would that
be the most cocksuckiness thing I could
do or should I get a speedo
thank you guys
I remember the thing that I was gonna
say wow okay so let's put this this
question is great I take back the thing
about the noseble I think it looks good
on them it actually does you look look
cool
um I remember the thing before we get
into okay go ahead
I was at the gym
I was working out you know as I do I was
getting my back all nice something like
that doing squats now something like
that is right yeah but I mean my [__]
was getting like I was sweaty because I
get into it oh were you getting a Yorkie
doodle dandied on your legs so
um I'll take that joke right for me
can't really do it anymore so but um
that's okay you know you went somebody
lose some but that was more of a tie so
um I'm gonna lose sleep over again so
Mississippi hasn't been so good lately
but so uh actually last two nights were
good anyway I'm getting sidetracked so
uh
let's reel it in let's reel it in what
if I forgot story at the gym dude come
on again so me I do that all the time
what I do that all the time I will be in
the middle of saying something yeah
completely forget what it was completely
dude and then just be like okay in my
head I'm going okay it's gone and
I'm like I don't want everybody to know
it's gone obviously so I'll just be like
I'll do something like this
it's just
ah you know oh wow you know and then
just pray for rain you know yes exactly
you know um and this guy was talking to
another guy walked by me
and said straight up and it I did not
hear it wrong he said it depends on the
different advices he was going to give
us what yeah did you look it was Arnold
Schwarzenegger no and I looked and I was
like oh he's gonna turn around and be
like I love the show right of course
yeah kept walking just set it for real
whoa yeah isn't that crazy that he
walked by me and did that by the way
yeah like like I heard that how many
seconds before you thought it might be
for you
no immediately oh oh really who the
[__] his advices I mean he was
American oh he didn't have an accent no
okay yeah if you had an accident I'd be
like oh wow I wouldn't even think it was
for us yeah I don't know people you know
what I've realized because of this show
people don't know how to say the thing
that they mean when they come on the
show or ask me for advice in one-on-one
they say the advice I came to you for
and it's like no you don't provide the
advice you ask things and I give you the
advice yeah but that's what they mean so
correcting them is pointless they don't
mean right right yeah you know it's just
like the way people
use the word advice is wrong almost
always they're probably nervous well I
make people nervous and I and I frankly
I always have made people nervous and
it's just this glint in my eye
it's my it's my vibe it's just like no
I've contained I possess multitudes
you're a menace I put I obtain I [__]
contain drunk altitude were you doing
that no I mean
[__] contain multitudes all right so
um this guy is great I am a big Speedo
guy he look you look like you're in I
have a question roughly you're in good
shape not I'm being like you here I
think but like I I don't know if I fully
understood the question he's saying
should I wear Speedos or not oh that's
it he's saying is it okay to wear
Speedos at like a I think there's an
apartment complex of course it is okay
and also like if you've got that nose
thing you're the man this Speedo is not
going to be the thing that people talk
about right it doesn't matter if you
literally were naked and had a ball peen
hammer swinging from the tip of your
[__] uncircumstances
why are you why are you doing it like no
dude I'm laying it down today John
Markovich lays it down maybe
anyway if you've got a ball peen hammer
swinging from the tip of your [__]
[__] I would not be looking at that I'd
be looking at the thing in your nose
and everyone else would do it in the
movie in the line of fire John Michael
which on the phone with Clint Eastwood
if you had a ball ping swinging around
your [__] deleted scenes
um so what we did here we cut this one
because it wasn't John Malkovich went
off the rails it wasn't quite you know
it makes it quite make sense
with with Goldman script no no who wrote
that I think you know who wrote it I
think it's somebody William Goldman
wrote that yeah damn really I'm good at
that knowing things I know things uh
they say he secretly wrote uh dog day no
he did right dog day they say he
secretly wrote
um Ben Affleck Matt Damon I don't think
they say it was him really secretly but
that I think that's a conspiracy but
that's what they say it's not a
conspiracy it's like a it's like an
unconfirmed rumor yeah that's not quite
a conspiracy no it's not because that's
the thing that people for a while and
they just don't know who did it I think
why don't you think it was them because
they never wrote anything ever yeah
that's that's why what I think happened
is they wrote the script right and
Harvey was like this will be a giant
money-making machine right if only it
was a good script so then he was like
I'm gonna hire a Ghostwriter who was the
man pay that writer a million dollars
but in that payment right right make
sure they don't keep credit you know
interesting uh because you know that
made those guys start that could if that
if that's what happened that could not
have worked yeah better no way even
close like that is the greatest possible
one in a million possible I know crazy
right anyway yeah uh yeah Speedos are
totally okay
um you know I I I I also the speedo
thing it's like people are already
looking at you making comments
like
just spread your legs
and the next time just only wear a
condom yeah just a condom be like sorry
I'm trying to get the tan maximized also
and then uh either another condom Magnum
which is the ones I'm familiar with if
you need advice let me know yeah because
you need those those are the ones that
go in your butt right and you put them
around your balls which are bigger than
typically the bigger than your dick and
then so you have two condoms dangling
um that's it that's what I got for you
we're a therapist
all right next
hi Matt hello hi Chris oh so didn't even
I want to say I saw you in Salt Lake so
she did so good okay rewind it I want to
see how she did it like that I want to
see it Vince Vaughn she did like she did
like me because I mean she wanted to see
me so let's not say
hi Matt okay hi Chris yeah dude it was
like he was disappointed in Salt Lake
yeah but she wasn't looking so good
she's making up for her now she's making
up for it we had the best time ever so
thank you
okay
I'm in this
mom group text in my neighborhood cool
that I don't want to be in oh and I've
asked politely to be removed from this
group text yeah three different times
oh I know what happened and they won't
do it and I can't leave the text message
why you know how you can go in and leave
yeah I can't what whoever created it has
to remove me oh that's like a uh
what do I do I've asked three times over
the last like two months keep getting
caught in this group dude that's so
funny I I didn't know you cannot how do
I do it without being rude how do I ask
yet again
thanks for your time
well you've asked there's a great end
shot there you you you you
asked politely three times right
yeah
yeah that's very weird it's like a black
hole once I ask the line of no return
you just can't get out it's like that's
that's not how it's supposed to it's
like the mafia is what it's like it's
like once you're in you're in for life I
feel like
what happened is
that
sir
um I feel like what happened is checking
her [__] stats you know it wasn't
dude
I was trying to think of the I was
trying to think of the term Event
Horizon but I didn't even need my phone
baby baby why were you trying to think
of the terms she passed the Event
Horizon and is now stuck in the black
hole and can't get out that's why you
were on your phone uh yeah but it didn't
need to be so but the [__] Mafia
thing was better no no mine's better
because it's smarter yours is better
because it's dorkier no well it's
smarter Mafia is better because I'm like
a real [__] house you're a [__]
Thug and they're stupid and they go to
jail okay scientists and Geniuses get
lauded in line no they go to jail too
look at the [__] uh
Bernie Madoff and the girl who did the
[__] he's not a scientist dude he's a
[__] con man
uh I think what happened is you asked
maybe okay let's put it this way you've
asked three times so maybe one time
it got buried
yeah give give it a great period one
time it got buried maybe two times it
got buried but maybe not maybe the
second time some people saw it and was
like oh it's not up I can't remove them
I think the person who started it just
maybe hadn't seen it text whoever
started to text them and be like yo
please take me off the root chain
because here's the problem if you the
the people who keep going back to that
group
even if they take you off
or then or even if they start a new one
when they go to type it in the thing for
the search the old one's going to come
up and you're going to get those texts
yeah so you have to go to the person who
started the text yeah and say you got to
take me off this thing this way this
text this way when any whenever anybody
texts from that you won't get it I took
it as a given that she went to the
person who started it but maybe no maybe
she didn't she probably just said it
dropped the text and dude dropping a
text on a chain of nine people the
chances that even three of them see that
text are low you know I mean like on
average it's like two or three probably
see it I'm on several threads like that
because I have a lot of friends and work
work Associates and stuff like that so
like I have a lot of big big text
changes a lot of people I don't have a
big social network and so
I don't
it's like I don't always see the things
and I miss out on conversations and then
like 100 texts came and I'm like I don't
know what somebody said 20 minutes ago
and I'll never know because I ain't
scrolling right dude I
was on a text chain I went to I I didn't
look at it for a few hours like I was
just in the living room and [__] like
with my family dude I picked up my phone
later
298 texts on one text chain oh I've had
that I've I've had that I swear to God
up to like 450. there's this one text
chain I'm on that is and has been going
on for like
12 years or something with three other
of my best friends and it's I'll leave
my phone sometimes for 30 minutes and
I'll come back there's 400 texts oh my
God it's how many how many people four
total oh my God yeah so it's just three
people doing that yeah
um so
yeah so that's what I would do if not
though you got to drive over to the
person that's the thing if that person
if you go directly to that person and
they still don't do it you got to say
when's a good time to come to you yeah
yeah yeah yeah wherever there you go
you'll hand me your phone you can look
over my shoulder make sure I don't do
anything nefarious
and you'll see how to do that's all I'll
teach you how to get rid of something
it'll be a lesson it'll be good for
everybody I'll give you a free lesson on
how to use your phone better that's it
want a free lesson yeah text that
exactly of what text removal yeah no
just say do you want a free lesson and
then then they say for what say it's
free who doesn't want a free lesson get
them to say yes
you know you want a free lesson yeah
what is it it doesn't matter you one for
Less everyone Something Free sure ding
dong you're already out there all right
so
um yeah that's good that's good advice
and thanks for coming to the show on
Salt Lake that one actually was a
special one thank you also sometimes
don't bypass it what I said but yeah
sometimes you just gotta be mean oh that
is true allow you
the respect of being nice
then you have no choice but to be mean
they're not giving you a choice and you
know how you have you know who you
actually have to tell this to a lot
people from Utah and she was in Salt
Lake City because Utah is full of smiles
okay and okay yeah Ohio everyone's great
Ohio or Utah she said oh no I don't like
that I liked it I liked it I didn't like
it I knew you wouldn't like it that's
why I was smiling and nodding before you
even said it's to get the positivity out
of it before I even got the negativity
go ahead
what a dumb [__] thing you know yeah
well all right oh you know all right
next okay
what's up Delia brothers and something
at you live from New York City a
beautiful guy with a pretty tough
dilemma I'm in late night talk shows
about three weeks and we've been on
about uh started over Matt talked over
it beautiful all right dude it's like
he's a painting in the 16th century
why is he rewinding it and not just why
don't you just he doesn't know how to do
it dude yeah Marco didn't tell him it's
Marco's fault not not his Anthony what
is up to Leah Brothers I'm coming at you
live from New York City with a pretty
tough dilemma I'm in so I've been dating
this girl for about three weeks and
we've been on about three dates
um and she's great she's beautiful funny
oh you know uh great in bed we really
get along well and I really like her
okay except for one thing oh boy she is
a horrible kisser
she kisses with her mouth fully a gape
sticks her tongue down my throat really
just doesn't know what she's doing in
that regard nice so I'm wondering if at
this stage in the relationship about
three weeks one month in is it okay for
me to make a comment on it and maybe try
to coach her on it a little bit or
should I break things off and try to
find a woman who sort of checks all the
boxes I mean obviously kissing is a
really important part of any
relationship and church I kind of take
uh more uh simple and surgical approach
to French kissing so
um it's important
uh
thorn in my side so I would love to
sharpening a knife that's on it and
thanks so much for the podcast guys
thanks okay first things first you're a
beautiful man secondly your serial
killer
hahaha
dude uh so butthead okay so why I I
don't let me first of all don't break up
with her do you gotta try to change not
but you don't want to do it like a sly
little devil you just gotta say
something like hey I I want to try
kissing in this one way will you try
this with me what do you mean no I'm a
master at this house
no but but just be like you don't want
to be like hey let me coach you at a
kiss yeah that's so rude and even if it
you even if it's true it'll alienate her
and make her feel like a [__] idiot
you don't wanna even if like you don't
want her to think that because that's
not even true she just cases differently
now that being said I've kissed people
who it's as if we learned kissing on
different planets in completely
different eras of our existence you pull
away and she's green with eyes she's
holding her eyes would be less of a
surprise than the way this some people
kiss oh that makes sense yeah
oh yes it's like the Mars Attacks people
like the jaw just opens yeah and then
the tongue is just like
that's my style disgusting it's so hot
to me it's like it's like a great it's
like abrasive is what it is yeah dude
not not it's not how people kiss but
here's here's what you got to wonder
beautiful man here's what you gotta
Wonder
she's kissed people before so
uh theoretically those people also
kissed that way because here's what
never happens this is a [__] this never
happened you gotta kiss somebody and you
the it's because it's your very first
kiss you're insecure you you match the
way they're doing it because you don't
know how to do it it's it's human nature
of course that's just like anything else
you're gonna follow the person who knows
how to do the thing there you go at
least in your mind but that yeah just
answered the question maybe that person
that she learned on was a terrible coach
terrible kisser terrible leader whatever
you want to call it and leader ruined
her ability to kiss for the rest of her
life now in this instance the reason I
painted this picture is that so you have
sympathy for her you don't want to be
like hey
you kiss bad let me show you you want to
be like hey you kiss different than me
can I show you like the way that I do it
like it's it's like make it a thing a
fun thing now go say the wrong thing
that's not right go ahead Chris and go
ahead and do the wrong thing you've been
talking too long you did say the right
answer in there somewhere but not the
point I only said one thing you said a
bunch of different things too correct as
I said I contain multitudes it's true I
mean just [__] gave up no it's true
immediately I said one thing no you
didn't you're right I said isn't that
one thing there are many budding flowers
of other things is my scientist so a
botanist so yeah I got it I said it
first so I got it I didn't need you
there well
um
ah
I've got two ideas that you might want
to explore one is
dude
it's probably not true
but make sure you're not the bad kisser
yeah but how do you do that the only way
you do that he's got great
looks and the lips and so I doubt it's
the hymn
but never know sometimes the best
looking people have the least clue how
to do anything because everybody's been
too afraid to correct them and also they
don't have to because they're just hot
right sure but that's another reason why
they would be afraid to have to it's
like nobody even approaches them about
how they do it because it's like that's
why they're sexier than me even though
that guy's not sexy me but yeah Josh
leederman
but so um so what you should do is not
what Matt said what you should do is
when you're kissing
say hey
whatever it is say you want it to slow
down or whatever slow down
slow down
boom get in and then
how how you know what I mean the reason
I wasn't looking is because I knew
you're gonna do something or or hey hey
hey hey hey hey
playing a game boy playing Game Boy
okay
boys so dumb so so
um
you have to make sure
that you're the lead here
you can't say hey I want to try which is
what Matt's [__] ass said or hey should
we do it like this which is what Matt's
[__] ass said
hey hey
check this out hey slow it down speed it
up do like this open your mouth let me
check it out like this a dentist
[Laughter]
so
um that kind of thing yeah and also then
make sure uh deep in your mind that uh
it's not you but but
that I don't know and those things make
me laugh so much yeah me too but that
kind of humor I don't think that's like
inherently not the right
it's hot right here in here
we're in the summertime here whoa
it's 150 degrees yes dude so go ahead uh
I [__] forgot oh oh you my you aren't
it's not that you're wrong it's that I'm
more right right so like you could do
what he said I actually believe that you
you could try that but like
there's something like
it's insincere sexy yeah no that's just
me you're trying to be sexy no no you're
not you know what you like and you're
letting her know hey there's what she
would want Anyway by the way she'd
rather that no I see I this is this is
the part only part we disagree on I
think it's better to be like
inviting instead of commanding
right no I don't think so yeah and
that's clear and that's why my advice is
better okay do you want to do the next
one Wow Let's do the next one I guess
different devices hey Matt hey Chris
do I have a question
to it oh boy so I have this Anonymous
person who had dm'd me a few years ago
asking for feet pictures I knew it
apparently I know this person I went to
school with this person
uses it on
anonymously I I don't know who the
person is so he offered fifty dollars
for feet picks and of course I without
hesitation yeah thank you thank you as
your time went on and the request got a
little more and more detailed slash
explicit yeah so I guess
I guess my question to you
is if you were by the way I'm in a
relationship if you were in a
relationship and your significant other
was receiving these messages from an
anonymous person asking for either
cheap picks News videos of me peeing
um my face is not in any of these photos
I just want your opinion so in our
relationship we have
developed a lot of trust so there's no
way that this exchange has gone beyond
like an internet communication okay
but I get paid a couple hundred dollars
it started with fifty dollars for the
feet pick and then
I don't want to get like too explicit
because I want you guys to get uh Shadow
band but wow another one was like a
photo of me and leggings with a camel
toe with my camel toe showing right
um and then recently he asked for a
video a lot more explicit right so
that's I kind of draw the line with some
of the all right oh my gosh I can't even
like fully finish I draw the line at
some of his requests yeah
either way my question is would you feel
comfortable if you were in a
relationship and your girlfriend Beyonce
or maybe even wife
was sending pictures for money
if you guys are trying to save for a
house
yeah and what because you're trying to
pay for a house here's the thing I don't
know here's the thing I don't think so
it's actually rather clear-cut to me
you shouldn't necessarily be opposed to
doing it but because it's because
everything you just said is the truth
you should just
involve your husband or boyfriend or
whoever and say this loser lunatic wants
to be to send him pictures of my
feet and like
my [__] outside my leggings I don't
think that's that loose
you could pay for nudes but it's like
some pathetic guy that like she might do
yeah well that's the weird thing to me
is like if it's somebody you knew then
it feels like he's getting off on he
knows you and you don't know him and
like he's making you do stuff even
though you are married or in a
relationship and I this is why you
involve the husband and then well you
definitely ownership of it yeah what I'm
saying is you don't even have to be like
hey I have something to con I mean
you've already done it too much so
that's I understand that's a problem but
what you should have done is after the
feet pick then like wait a second that
wasn't the right thing I should have
consulted whatever that wasn't the most
trustworthy act go to him and you should
have gone to him and said hey we can
make a little extra money are you
comfortable with this if the answer is
no then you don't do it yeah yeah yeah
but if the answer is yes which it could
very well be again if you're trying to
buy a house every dollar counts right
yeah but she was asking us if we'd be
comfortable with that and my answer is
no absolutely not no no no no no no if
that's the question not even at all if I
learned that about my partner I mean I
would just be like
I would be so mad at her yeah me too I
would be so mad so would I you know if
they were sending even feet pics I'd be
like what are you doing I wouldn't be so
mad if it was just feed picks like if if
Kristen came to me and she was like dude
some guy offered me
I mean she would never do this for 50
but I don't know if she would but she
was like a 50 feet picks I well it would
be so weird so I would be like for fifty
dollars like so she if she was like okay
give me five grand for feed picks yeah
I'd be like well why did you do this and
not tell me about it I wouldn't have
thought that about defeat anything
beyond the feet if beyond the feet the
way people are about yeah I'm the feet
the foot fetish is so absurd and
disgusting to me oh really I don't even
consider it sexual it's so ludicrous
it's like if somebody wanted my
girlfriend to like
pay her like like you said five grand
for a few pics of her feet she did it
and then didn't tell me I wouldn't even
think a thing about it I just feel like
got it good job you got five grand but I
mean then there's pictures of her vagina
right right that's a totally different
ball oh yeah that's not yeah yeah I
agree I agree I agree actually be on the
feet yeah beyond the feet starring
Michael Kane and Toby Maguire well worst
movie of all time uh both of those
people in Cider House Rules yeah movies
I was imagining they were in a house and
talking about you can't keep sending
pictures or just your feet right most
boring movie
to see that movie
um all right directed by yes we would
care a lot Aaron Aronofsky and let me
tell you something else so would every
other guy so like yeah yeah also so
would Every Other Woman no no nobody's
cool with that anyway you know what I
think you know that because the part
that you laughed at was right when it
was like
it was like you knew the answer that we
were gonna give you and deep down you
know the answer that you think obviously
that's not cool
yeah I'm not saying you're like a [__]
up person no no no you're not the deal
if you're gonna go to your husband
boyfriend whatever and say Hey listen I
[__] up
yeah uh this guy offered me money for
feed picks I thought nothing of it
because it's just fee yeah one thing
turning to another I I got caught up in
the stupid thing I sent him pictures of
me and leggings I I know it's dumb and I
feel really badly that if if my wife
came to me like that yeah exactly I
would be like hurt but I would I would
be very more I would be way more
empathetic and understanding but if if
you're like
dude what if it's her husband I thought
the same thing you thought that before I
did yeah I thought while she was talking
I was like it's her husband you are dude
uh for even if she just says it and he's
like
I know exactly shows her the pics yeah
uh then he'd be the [__] [__] and
then I'd be like that leave that
relationship right now yeah
um all right so you have a bunch of
answers and a bunch of hypotheticals and
a bunch of uh good advices from us yeah
that was a good question great question
and we get why you want it to be
anonymous yep
polish Stephen Soderberg what's up Chris
what's up Matt uh congratulations Chris
on the new addition to the family thanks
dude
um congratulations Matt on keeping your
life a secret you guys are sick uh let's
get it thank you for noticing um
my really good friend came to me
and
he's been having problems with his best
friend of like 14 years it's a while ago
his best friend was seeing his ex he
dated this girl for like five years and
then his friends started seeing her
and he messed him up but that's how he
found out it didn't work out and then he
kind of started talking to him again
well now we just found out
he's now dating his most recent ex oh
dude are you and he's like
yeah he's gonna lose it he spun up he's
trying really hard not to show it like I
could tell it was yeah with this other
guy I didn't really know what to say all
I said was
did you ask him if your wiener tasted
good okay just try to make him laugh but
okay yeah okay hopefully you guys can
give me some much better all right
thanks guys dude that's what is up with
this other guy uh
I mean I that's like yeah the guys just
got a real big problem right the other
guy the guy that's dude yeah uh the
other guy's just like trying to still be
friends with him and letting him back in
like that's normal yeah that's fine that
dude is [__] up that's terrible dude
people I know people like that everybody
knows people like that whether they
realize it or not they know people like
that but like dude that is not me
that is a nobody that is a poison person
there are people like that that it's
just like doesn't matter I found that
out it doesn't matter what's going on in
their life it doesn't matter who they're
friends with doesn't matter what age
they are I bet they're made out of
[__] poison dude yeah they're just
bad people like this and honestly I
don't like that that I'm saying this but
like you shouldn't even let that guy
back in if they did it wouldn't be as
good my [__] dude shut up [__] up all
right I can see your balls basically if
you do the horizontal with mambo with me
I'm Unforgettable dude okay okay do you
have advice or you just want to talk
about that yeah I do
find out the guy's exes and try to have
sex with them I mean
so petty no I mean dude I don't that's
drop that dude
you're saying fight him no no drop it
drop him as a friend yeah uh no don't
ever fight yeah that's yeah you don't
need that kind of [__] in your life I
mean obviously but I have buddy I had a
buddy that would try and do that never
was successful because I like again same
guy I know oh yeah yeah we know yeah
okay I lay it down
I mean he did try to be me too really
yeah that's a weirdo that's that's what
I'm talking about yeah but I know more
than one person like that but I know I'm
sure you're talking about yeah I mean
did it to me so you know I'm talking
about someone I'm very very close to you
so I know very well
um so yeah no I uh that's like you know
this is the kind of stuff you know it
happens but when you hear it you're like
well come on
um yeah that guy's got to drop the guy
the advice is for him though you got to
tell the dude to drop the other guy well
he's obviously gonna do that but I think
I think yeah okay make sure that guy
never is friends with that guy ever
again yeah yeah but also like you have
the right Instinct if you're trying to
cheer him up make him laugh and
highlight the absurdity of the situation
the the the the worst thing to possibly
draw from that is that that's how male
friends are yeah because that is not
true no most male friends would not do
that even in the first place yeah let
alone twice in a row and the second time
when you're patching things up after the
first time like this guy's like
a psycho like a psychopath well he's
probably getting maybe he's even getting
off on it which is right then it's like
you're a pawn in his twist it's a kink
yeah probably yeah which is so which is
weird because it's like
that's an interesting question is that
like a homosexual Kink because like the
target is the man no but that you're
involving the man but it's not a
homosexual King homosexual is Dick and
butt and that's it I mean I don't agree
with that yeah homosexuals dick and butt
well I know no that's not a wonder that
means guys like homosexual sex or a girl
like men is a dick in a butt yeah there
you go
you can be homosexual and not [__] a guy
though
if you just want to so that's what I'm
saying maybe not the word circuitous
indirect kinkers where he's like
he's getting off specifically on hurting
the guy which I'm asking no that's okay
okay that's just Twisted you know what
if you saw my balls you'd know so don't
say like you could see my balls almost
I have shorts man all right if you saw
my balls you'd know okay well that's
actually true of everyone's balls no one
my balls are big look at someone balls
and not someone's balls and not know my
balls are big that's not even good
they're so grotesquely huge I need to
get it checked
and it's not good okay you have
elephantitis of the balls yep cool man
like Stan Marsh when he's willing
wheelbarrowing them out around and then
one episode of South Park he did that
show's so funny it is okay what's up we
got one more um
what's up Chris and Matt I'm the real
Thor so I'm here in Asgard
and there's no way that that's Odin has
just been a day Adam Levine song
[Music]
wow
you did it dude lost
his mind my favorite part is because I
said it look at Thor my favorite part is
people who have not seen the episode
where you're doing that then saw him do
that and are so clueless about what's
going on and oh I hate this guy because
of it because you hit this guy no oh if
I didn't see your [__] though yeah and
so I'd be like this guy's a [__]
[__] I feel the exact opposite that's
funny you like everything about it you
would and start it over please Anthony I
think he deserves the respect he does he
does he does have an honor for the sheer
ballsness of it look he figured it out
because marker never would have figured
it out yep minute episode Anthony's
better
what's up Chris and Matt just your call
I'm just listening right now
and there's no way that that song isn't
oh a Adam Levine song
[Music]
wow that's
right I'll eat lost his
so sexy
he just said so handsome handsome
dude wearing no pants that's the end of
the song
I mean is that there's no advice he
thinks it's actually Adam Levine who
sings I guess so yeah he's suggesting
the possibility that's Adam Levine while
not knowing whether it really is Oh I
thought then why is he doing the eat all
I don't have any idea I thought maybe he
thought it was a real song that does
that maybe he does maybe he does is
there a song where Adam Levine he said
it wrong in life he said it wrong
someone pissed at him no he just said
the whole thing wrong he didn't say it's
that song by Adam Levine he said it
sounds like an Adam Levine song
right yeah
he's writing Adam Levine love and life
oh
no no no no that's the yeah no he lied
he lied he was a sexy guy and he lied
okay dude go to the next dude oh is that
the next guy a real guy let's do another
one
the [__] Scott wolf I mean dude what up
Chris what up Matt uh uh I have a
question that I need a tick tocker
Johnny Bravo it is regarding my roommate
and I watch hey Chris
he does his thing that drives me crazy
okay and he takes my hair dryer box
during the movie whether it's asking me
questions about the movie don't ask me
questions this is both of our first
times watching yeah dude thank you
that's funny or he's just like making
side comments through the whole movie so
annoying also
House of [__] is it to be on a bike
that's too tall for you when you're
trying to get off well yeah that's good
that's that's I just wanted to bring
that that is big but yeah thank you any
advices would be great yeah he really
understands he does get it's a [__] but
he doesn't understand it that he would
just say how [__] is it he said how's
the [__] is it and that's not right
it's not wrong it's not like yeah some
people say Sosa [__] that's wrong it
you just say isn't it [__] it's so
[__] when a guy does it but he's got
the right sense of what [__] is he's
right though I think he can say okay all
right either in either case he's Johnny
Bravo because of his hair so either case
he's Scott wolf okay so Scott wolf plays
Johnny Bravo in the [__] a 24 film so
what does he say idiot what does he say
it's called Bravo with Scott wolf what
was the first thing him not you hey I'll
just uh my my legs are too small for my
body
okay uh um
what was his question exactly
oh you're talking through movies oh yeah
dude
Thomas shut the [__] [__] up it's
that simple you know what I do
this is what I do because Kristen don't
just you do that man I do yeah but I do
it for the good one I do the good ones
everybody thinks they do the good ones
but I also pause it when I do it that's
even more annoying so I'm out of without
asking pauses it what what you know what
Kristen does dude it will be like a
whole scene with no dialogue okay and
then
a guy will go
and then Chris will be like did you read
the email and I'm just like babe he took
a huge breath you know his
you know he's gonna talk for
yeah dude it's so annoying here's
something that it's just probably so not
true but it's something I deeply feel
and will probably never not feel I feel
like I know when to talk and other
people me too have no idea no me too
really that's weird dude I I'm I'm like
this
you talk then yeah action sequence you
talk then yeah you don't talk when
people are like revealing information
dude it's insane yeah yeah yeah yeah
chicks be really doing that it even
bothers me when I'm watching the Mets
and someone like this big long it's
annoying when anyone's talking when
anyone says Keith Hernandez starts to
talk and someone's just like yeah oh
Matt did you and I'm just like yeah yeah
wait a second I hate it I hate it I hate
it
um and then and then you seem like a
dick when you pause it and go back
they're like oh sorry talk over your
thing that's my move though that's my
move my move is when Kristen does that I
go like this
I I literally go like this
uh-huh so she knows what's up but that's
what I just said yeah you said it's dick
when they when they act like they're put
out when you've gotten purpose good no
I'm no no no no no
what I'm saying is you when you do that
in your case Christian if you were to do
that and Christian's like oh I'm sorry
did I talk about that movie I say yes
that's dick but it's too late they
already they already committed the crime
she's already dick yeah if that happened
it's like a crime it's like in a
concurrent additional sentence yes there
you go yeah yeah and for this she should
go to jail for that well for a few days
yeah whatever a week no um
no yeah it's it's just it's it's talking
during movies is okay it is okay just do
it at the right times have this
conversation with them if he's doing it
at the wrong times that's a crime if
he's not doing it at the wrong times if
he's doing it when one guy's in a car
driving it's gonna be okay action
sequence yeah if he does it during walls
that's on you dude Montage he's doing it
right yeah if he's doing it when it's
there are laws there's the it's the art
of movie talking really but also what if
he's just annoying he might just be
saying the guy's annoying him whenever
he says his roommate right yeah so then
yeah you can't not watch movies with him
so right yeah you just you then do the
thing I did pause it and turn to him
it'll take six hours to watch the movie
but yeah yeah that guy's got to know
he'll get it okay and and uh also
there's I mean it's just
yeah I mean has he had the conversation
with him I don't know probably not he
could be like yo bro stop talking during
the [__] move that's what I said try
that first yeah absolutely be like hey
why are you always talking yeah during
the times we're supposed to be listening
to something I'm trying to watch
something working most of the day you
can say anything anytime you want why
don't you just wait stop I'm doing
calisthenics okay so yeah I I agree
that's horrible but the guy has a
[__] [__] and ass hair his hair was
one of a kind as far as non-cartooned
humans yep his hair was tippy top
and for that reason he's my best friend
wow yeah
okay I'm gonna email him after this okay
Chris yeah big fan of the podcast love
what you guys do beautiful voice
beautiful voice
oh yeah
thank you many more wow just walking my
son
[Music]
look at that boy um so quick question
for you guys my friends here visiting
and we're going to all the movies you're
watching me younger I'm 32 years old now
so in our teens we used to watch um
and obviously now you don't get anything
that
could is there a reason why is it the
whole world culture yeah yeah is it you
know people are just scared to make you
know movies that push boundaries anymore
I don't know let me know your thoughts
um love you guys keep up the good work
see ya thanks buddy you want an adorable
son you want to know movies that push
boundaries
look at movies that were made before
Talladega nice bro if that's what you're
looking for go further back yeah don't
look at stuff now you want to find
[__] movies with cajones Mega big
nuts yeah you go back in time you don't
go to the movie theater in 2023. yeah
dude everything is made for as many
people as possible to go see it which
means families yeah exactly which means
a 32 year old man is not gonna think it
had [__] kahanas I know and that
literally like in the 80s they probably
made a movie called Somewhere well I
mean that's not exactly I know
believe it or not but I'm just saying
like they didn't give a [__] no they
weren't they weren't catering to anybody
they were just like we're gonna do well
whoever I mean there's all different
kinds of movies so it's true of comedies
it's true of action movies it's true of
Dramas it's true of horror you get just
way more wild [__] being made because
they don't feel like somebody's watching
them over their shoulder telling them
that everything they did is wrong or
offensive or bad for this or bad for
that everybody was kind of operating
doesn't know this [__] but like yeah but
if you go back yeah it's insane just go
further back dude don't don't bother and
your kid will be better off for it
you'll see older [__] have a wider scope
of like what's interesting and like kill
that's a bigger cooler brain and you
know he'll be better served but what
he's saying is a generational thing too
though there are there will always be
that when I was younger things were
better no matter what happened but
that's not even what he's saying he's
not saying no he's not saying that well
okay I mean I assume that's what he
meant but he's also objectively correct
about movies if you said it about life
in general sure that's what everybody
says about everything yeah generation
always right yeah but about movies it's
just true
over the years to the point now that
even you know like
everything is either animated a sequel
or already a popular book or video game
the original stuff now is like next to
zero and when it is adapted it's way
watered down you know it's just like
it's it's tough dude but uh the good
news is you got like you know 100 years
worth of stuff made before even the odds
which of the movies you're talking about
was when they were made so just go
backwards man just look at like random
lists you find online like what's the
best of this kind of movies that kind of
movie what's the most like you know
craziest comedy like I mean it's like
the movie your highness you know like
Blazing Saddles you want to like know I
know I'm not talking but I am I'm saying
okay go ahead uh yeah but like if you
want crazy comedies dude just like seven
blazing 70s I mean yeah would straight
up never make them no no way dude and if
they did it wouldn't be Mel Brooks who
made it yeah true
um true yeah maybe Ben Shapiro's company
um all right uh that's it great thank
you very much Lifeline dude uh I'll be
in uh Knoxville Nashville and uh
Charlotte and Las Vegas let's go come
through Little Rock Little Rock Arkansas
uh get your merch at lifelinemirch.com
sign up for our patreon to get the extra
shows uh patreon.com Lifeline luxury uh
and uh leave a comment what water you
like what water is the [__] what's
wrong with Arrowhead but also the other
bad Waters Dasani Aquafina and what else
yeah arrowhead's not the worst water uh
Aquafina and Dasani are if you on a
one-on-one appointment with me solve all
your problems like that
uh matchelia.com book your session now
get that merch what is It lifetime
merch.com you already said that
I did do that okay great get your merch
or else you hate me thanks guys
subscribe
[Music]